and I think that's what anybody wants
just really good work and keep the
family together and happy and just enjoy
life you know it's like life was too
short gotta live it Kelly Preston has
died at the age of 57 the actress died
on Sunday morning after a two-year long
battle with breast cancer a rep for the
family told people kelly chose to keep
her fight private but had been
undergoing medical treatment for some
time her husband john travolta confirmed
the news in an emotional post on
instagram he lamented quote it is with a
very heavy heart that I inform you that
my beautiful wife Kelly has lost her
two-year battle with breast cancer she
fought a courageous fight with the love
and support of so many Kelly's love and
life will always be remembered when I
first saw the scene where he's on the
bleachers that was like oh be still my
heart John and Kelly met in 1987 on the
set of the comedy the experts they tied
the knot in 1991 so proud of him and I
think he's just best Kelly appeared in
dozens of TV shows and movies like Jerry
Maguire but it was a face a college
thing like torn Levi's or law school for
you want anything from the kitchen I'm
gonna get some fresh and she frequently
acted in roles opposite her husband I am
very lucky
her most recent big-screen appearance
came in the 2018 mob biopic Gotti she
starred as Victoria Gotti wife of the
crime boss John Gotti played by John I
already buried a son
you want me to bury another that you
will bury me too
the couple shares three children 20 year
old daughter Ella 9 year old son
Benjamin and their son jet who died in
2009 at the age of 16 Ella also took to
Instagram on Sunday to honor her late
mother writing in part quote thank you
for your love thank you for your help
and thank you for making this world a
better place you have made life so
beautiful and I know you will continue
to do so always after news broke of
Kelly's death some of Hollywood's
biggest stars headed to social media to
express their condolences Josh GAD
tweeted that he was in absolute shock
adding what a beautiful and amazing
actress and person Russell Crowe shared
a story about meeting Kelly in 1992
writing that she has remained the same
sparkly eyed Jem Holly Robinson Peete
called Kelly a beautiful lady inside and
out adding that her death is a crushing
loss Maria Shriver tweeted that Kelly
was such a bright loving soul a talented
actress and a loving mom and wife
you